we have now heard if you look nationally
from County election officials
state election officials state
legislators we have heard from all of
these different levels about a very
specific sort of plan
we know that there were elements to this
attempted coup that went all the way to
the White House it included the January
6 rioters the halls of Congress fake
electors in various States pressure
phone calls attempts to commandeer
voting machines remember every one of
these little details would have been a
crisis if Obama had done it that's for
sure
but they are just yet another instance
when it comes to Trump